Donc ces trois passages démontrent clairement les privilèges qui ont ceux qui font partie de la nouvelle alliance.
Ceux qui peuvent contempler et réjouir de la rédemption glorieuse des dieux,
la même rédemption que Dieu a développée au long de toute l'histoire de l'humanité depuis la chute,
mais qui a été déversée d'une manière spéciale pour ceux qui sont après la venue et la consommation de l'œuvre du Christ.
Et donc nous allons bientôt faire la transition de la considération de cette alliance des grâces
qu'on a contemplée et considérée dans la semaine dernière dans l'Ancien Testament.
Et nous allons aujourd'hui passer à la nouvelle alliance.
Et nous allons commencer par la lecture de la confession de foi.
Nous allons lire aujourd'hui pour la première fois les troisièmes paragraphes.
Donc si on peut passer, Christian.
Merci.
Et donc voici les textes de la confession de foi.
Je vous ferai quelques rappels au fur et à mesure.
Mais premier paragraphe en nous rappelant de la première alliance entre Dieu et Adam avant la chute.
Cette alliance des vies qu'on connaît plus avec la notion de l'alliance des œuvres.
Ensuite, le deuxième paragraphe qui nous parle de l'impossibilité
que l'humanité puisse traiter avec Dieu après la chute
par aucune autre base
qui ne soit une base de totale dépendance de la grâce des dieux.
Et donc l'alliance des grâces est par nécessité la seule manière
à travers laquelle l'homme peut mener une relation avec Dieu après la chute.
C'est par nécessité, comme on verra,
aucune conception d'aucune alliance
qui Dieu ne pourrait établir avec l'homme après la chute
ne pourrait plus être à nouveau une alliance
sous la condition de l'obéissance humaine.
Donc ça, c'est confessionnel, c'est clair, c'est biblique.
Et ensuite, le troisième paragraphe qui nous parle
de manière plus claire sur la révélation progressive
de cette une et seule alliance des grâces
divisée entre deux grandes dispensations,
l'ancienne alliance et la nouvelle.
Et donc nous allons lire ensemble,
juste pour commencer à nous habituer avec les textes confessionnels.
et nous allons, les prochaines fois,
nous plonger plus dans les implications doctrinaires.
Pour l'instant, on est plutôt en train de permettre
que les langages de la confession
nous poussent plus vers un langage biblique, organique,
si vous voulez, avant d'être plus technique
et commencera avec les aspects doctrinaux qui sont là aussi.
Donc la distance entre Dieu et la créature
est si grande que des créatures rationnelles
qui pourtant lui doivent obéissance du fait qu'il est créateur
n'auraient jamais obtenu la vie comme récompense,
n'aient été une condescendance à la part des dieux
qu'il ne s'est plus à exprimer par les moyens de l'alliance.
Donc, même si, quelque part,
les mantiens de cette alliance avant la chute
dépendaient d'une capacité réelle
que les êtres humains avaient avant la chute
d'obéir Dieu,
de garder cette alliance par leur effort,
la confession, elle est en train de nous rappeler
que même cette alliance
ne pourrait jamais suggérer à l'être humain
qu'il aurait pu réclamer quelque chose
de manière méritoire devant Dieu.
Elle est en train de nous rappeler
quelle est la place de l'homme
et même si Dieu a établi cette première alliance
en permettant à l'homme,
par l'obéissance,
d'aboutir
à un nouveau niveau de vie
ou de bénédiction,
cela a été déjà un acte
de condescendance à la part de Dieu.
Tout traitement que Dieu puisse faire
envers les êtres humains,
on sait que Dieu n'est pas notre égal
et c'est de la part de la grâce
et de la connaissance.
Donc même l'alliance primaire avec Adam,
l'alliance d'obéissance,
de la loi ou de la vie,
c'était une alliance
dont son essence était aussi la grâce.
OK ?
Et donc,
le deuxième paragraphe
nous rappelle de notre condition
après la chute.
Bien plus,
puisque l'homme s'est placé
sous la malédiction de la loi
par sa chute,
il a plu au Seigneur
de faire une alliance des grâces.
Et donc,
non seulement l'homme
dépend toujours de la grâce de Dieu,
même pour entrer dans une alliance d'œuvres,
à partir du moment
où on a échoué dans la première alliance
et on a perdu notre innocence originale,
notre capacité d'obéir,
on est doublément dans une condition
où nous sommes totalement dépendants
de la grâce de Dieu.
Si jamais la fin de l'humanité
ne sera pas à l'enfer,
si jamais la possibilité
de réconciliation avec Dieu
est une réalité,
cela ne peut dépendre
dans aucun cas
ni aucune mesure
des efforts humains.
On est totalement dépendants
que Dieu établisse une nouvelle alliance,
une alliance rédemptrice,
et voilà pourquoi on appelle cette alliance
une alliance des grâces.
Le premier pourquoi,
c'est car c'était impossible
que Dieu traite avec l'humanité
sur aucun autre terme.
Et donc, bien sûr,
je vous anticipe,
il y aura des implications
pour certains qui cherchent
de voir l'alliance mosaïque
comme une républication
de l'alliance des œuvres.
La confession de foi,
elle est claire
et clairement contraire
à cette notion.
Et donc,
par nécessité,
il faut que cette alliance
soit une alliance des grâces
et Dieu a décidé,
il a plu au Seigneur.
C'est parti des dieux.
Ce n'était pas l'humanité
qui immédiatement
après la chute
est venue en courant
envers Dieu,
en soupliant
une nouvelle opportunité.
Au contraire,
Adam et Ève
voulaient se cacher des dieux.
Et la Bible est l'histoire
d'un Dieu généreux
qui vient nous chercher.
Donc, c'est Dieu
qui a proposé
cette alliance des grâces
dans laquelle
il offre gratuitement
aux pécheurs
la vie.
Donc, la vie
ne sera plus retrouvée
sous la condition
de notre obéissance.
Elle est offerte
aux pécheurs
dans leur condition
d'impossibilité de sortie.
Elle est salue
par Jésus-Christ
rééquirant d'eux
la foi
en lui
pour être sauvée.
Et donc,
la foi,
on aurait pu penser
comme une condition,
sauf que c'est une condition
qui en elle-même
est un don des dieux
et être une condition
totalement passive.
La foi,
c'est la totale désistance
de chercher
toute ou la moindre
confiance en nous-mêmes
et d'ouvrir
nos mains vides
pour embrasser
la provision des dieux
pour notre rédemption.
Et donc,
il promet
à un autre
de donner son esprit,
donc là,
c'est
l'accomplissement
de cette promesse,
à tous ceux
qui sont destinés
à la vie éternelle
pour les rendre désireux
et capables
de croire.
OK ?
Donc,
les dons de l'esprit,
c'est les mêmes
qui nous capacitent
à croire,
à nous répentir,
c'est un don des dieux.
OK ?
Et donc là,
c'est le deuxième paragraphe,
l'emphase principale,
c'est la nécessité absolue
pour nous,
dans notre condition pécheresse,
que Dieu établisse
une nouvelle alliance,
une alliance des grâces.
Sangulier,
paragraphe 3,
cette alliance,
une seule alliance,
est révélée dans l'Évangile.
Tout d'abord,
Adam,
dans la promesse du salut
par la postérité de la femme
et par la suite,
progressivement,
jusqu'à sa révélation complète
dans les Nouveaux Testaments.
Elle est fondée
dans l'alliance
aux transactions éternelles
entre les pères et les fils
concernant la rédemption
des élus.
Ce n'est qu'à la grâce
de cette alliance
que tout membre
de la postérité d'Adam déchu,
a jamais été sauvé
et a obtenu
la vie
et la bienheureuse
immortalité
puisque maintenant,
l'homme est complètement
capable d'être accepté
par Dieu
dans les conditions
qui étaient valables
pour Adam
dans son état d'innocence.
Donc,
c'est un résumé,
bien sûr,
très précis,
très biblique
et c'est intéressant
de remarquer
que ça répond
à plusieurs questions
qui sont très récourantes
comme par exemple,
comment ont été sauvés
les saints réels
de l'Ancien Testament
avant la venue du Christ.
Donc,
la réponse ici,
elle est claire.
Tous ceux qui ont déjà
été sauvés
et qui ne seront jamais sauvés,
même avant la venue du Christ,
ils croyaient
par anticipation
dans les fils
qui viendraient
et ils croyaient
dans la mesure suffisante
de la grâce
de Dieu
qui avait été communiquée.
Dieu disait,
je pourvoirai
les sacrifices nécessaires.
Vous pouvez contempler
ces ombres,
ces types,
mais un jour,
il viendra
pour accomplir parfaitement
tous ces types représentent.
Et donc,
voilà,
juste pour nous habituer
avec les langages
de la confession
et on avance
pour considérer
des éléments
qu'on a déjà vus.
La première leçon,
juste un petit résumé,
les rappels principaux,
c'est de nous rappeler
qu'on pense
à la théologie
d'alliance
ou la théologie
des alliances
plus réelles,
nous sommes plutôt
en train de penser
à quelque chose
qui n'est pas
les principales
à propos de la rédemption.
On est en train
de parler
de la suture,
de l'encadrement
et l'exhortation
principale pour nous,
c'est quand on devient
plus intéressé
au débat polémique,
théologique
qu'à la substance.
Et donc,
quelque part,
même si les théologiens
ne peuvent pas s'empêcher
et nous-mêmes,
en lisant la Bible,
d'identifier ces cadres,
cette suture d'alliance
dans la manière
dont Dieu nous sauve,
la manière
dont ils découvrent ça,
c'est imprégné
de l'expérience
glorieuse
des rédemptions.
Donc, quelque part,
l'objectif pour la première leçon
pour nous,
c'était d'avoir
une attitude d'adoration
et de contempler
la glorieuse rédemption
des dieux
et de voir
quelle est la place
de l'étude
de la suture d'alliance
dans ces plans
de rédemption
beaucoup plus glorieux.
Donc, je ne vais pas
rentrer et revenir
sur tous les aspects
du plan de rédemption
qu'on a vu,
mais bien sûr
qu'ils vont transparaître
dans nos études
sur l'alliance
et les derniers points,
les points neufs,
nous disent tout simplement
que cette rédemption
a été,
révélée
par la suture
des alliances.
Donc, c'est juste
pour rappeler
de ne pas perdre de vue
ce qu'il y a
de plus glorieux
par rapport
à notre rédemption
quand on est en train
de rentrer
dans les détails
plus théologiques.
Donc, en résumé
du plan de la rédemption,
dans les prochains slides,
la rédemption est le plan
éternel, défini et immuable
des dieux,
préparé avant
la fondation du monde,
établi par les trois
personnes de la Sainte Trinité,
centré sur Christ,
structuré dans les cadres
d'une alliance,
révélée progressivement
par des alliances
successives.
C'est un plan
absolument certain
et destiné
à la gloire des dieux
seuls.
OK ?
Jusque-là,
on a déjà...
On est tous ensemble ?
OK.
Donc,
ce qu'on a vu
la semaine dernière,
dans la leçon 2,
c'était
de chercher
à définir
essentiellement
l'alliance
et donc
on s'est plongé
surtout
dans un survol
sur toutes les alliances
de l'Ancien Testament
mais
l'objectif
immédiat
n'était pas
voilà,
de déclarer
ouvertement
dès le départ
nous allons étudier
l'alliance des grâces
dans l'Ancien Testament.
Non,
l'intérêt
c'était
du lieu de nous laisser
porter
par la définition
théologique
ou technique
de ce qui sont
les alliances
on a voulu
faire cet exercice
ensemble
d'aller vers la Bible
et de remarquer
que c'est impossible
de ne pas constater
cette structure
d'alliance
dans la manière
dont Dieu
a développé
ou communiqué
son plan de rédemption.
la manière progressive
dont il a fait
et donc
on est allé
envers plusieurs
alliances
des anciens
testaments
avec l'objectif
de chercher
nous-mêmes
à former
notre conception
de ce qu'est
l'alliance
avant de présenter
une définition.
Pourquoi ?
De manière très basique
et essentielle
la notion commune
d'alliance
c'est tout simplement
un accord
formel
entre deux parties
qui a
des conditions
et des récompenses.
Ok ?
Quand on pense
à cette définition
théologique
pour ce qui concerne
une alliance
que Dieu
puisse faire
donc dans la définition
théologique
nous allons
remarquer
en fait que
quand on est en train
de parler
de l'alliance
des dieux
avec l'homme
on n'est pas
entre deux parties
égales.
On voit dans l'histoire
qui est ni toutes
les alliances
sont établies
entre deux parties
égales.
Je vous ai raconté
cette expérience
entre une nation
qui a pu dominer
une autre
et qui établit
un accord
qui est plutôt
comme en termes
des renditions
et qui dit
si vous ne vous accordez
pas à nos conditions
nous allons
vous supprimer
mais on vous donne
la possibilité
de participer
à notre empire
à notre royaume
réjouir
des bonnes choses
de ces royaumes
si vous obéissez
aux conditions.
Donc quelque part
ce ne sont pas
deux parties égales
mais il y aura
des sanctions
des récompenses
des punitions
des deux côtés
des conditions
et un accord formel
et établi.
Ok ?
Et donc
quand il s'agit
des dieux
c'est déjà
complètement et tellement
de l'initiative
divine
que les alliances
puissent avoir lieu
entre dieux
et les hommes
et nous devons garder
toujours à l'esprit
cette notion
des condescendants
de la part des dieux.
Il doit quelque part
se rébaisser.
Ok ?
Bien sûr que dieux
dans toutes ses interactions
il sera dieux
donc il sera bon
ok ?
Envers nous
ça sera toujours
au bénéfice
des êtres humains
mais en même temps
le fait que ça soit
quelque part
un attribut divin
ça n'oblige pas
dieux
d'agir comme ça
envers nous.
Et donc
c'est intéressant
la participation
de l'humanité
dans cette alliance
est une participation
bien sûr
qui est volontaire
un accord
c'est pas quelque chose
tout simplement
imposé
de la part
des dieux
mais la préoccupation
légitime
des théologiens
c'est pas si Adam
a voulu ou non
participer à cette alliance
c'est clair
implicite
même si implicite
c'est clair
qu'il s'était
de son mieux
intérêt
et c'est impossible
d'imaginer
qu'il n'aurait pas
voulu
cette opportunité
donnée par dieux
mais de toute manière
c'est intéressant
de remarquer
la préoccupation
théologique
c'est par rapport
à l'intérêt
des dieux
et donc
pour ça
certains théologiens
préfèrent
n'utiliser les termes
alliance
pour éviter
de suggérer
trop
que l'homme
rentre dans cette alliance
comme une partie légitime
et que ça soit
tout simplement
vu comme une promesse
déterminée par dieux
qui le va déverser
et donc
ils vont appeler
les testaments
voilà
des fois
c'est pas tout simplement
l'usage
de l'Ancien et Nouveau Testament
mais même les théologiens
quand ils vont parler
de l'alliance
et donc ça c'est pas très précis
pour plus que la motivation
c'est correct
mais
la Bible elle est claire
que les alliances
vont engager
les êtres humains
et surtout
les représentants
des êtres humains
comme une partie
qui doit accomplir
sa partie
dans cette alliance
ok
et donc
l'alliance biblique
voilà
dans notre compréhension
d'alliance
on a
on peut passer là
non
on reste là
pardon
les premiers points
qu'on a vu
c'est que l'alliance
des vies
avant la chute
c'était
voilà
une alliance
qu'on appelle
l'alliance des vies
l'alliance des lois
ou l'alliance des oeuvres
et c'est très important
pour nous
surtout quand on arrivera
aux discussions
par rapport aux positions
des variétés
par rapport à l'alliance
donc
juste pour vous avancer
nous avons
trois positions
générales
dans la réforme
donc il y a
la position
traditionnelle
fédéraliste
voilà
qui va affirmer
clairement
une seule alliance
de dispensation
mais qui se portera
plus à ce qu'on appelle
une hyper continuation
et qui vont chercher
à appliquer
même
les symboles
les signes
de cette alliance
donc les presbytériens
les pédobaptistes
de manière générale
les symboles
avec la même continuité
sur la surcharge
de la formalité
des alliances
de l'Ancien Testament
de l'autre côté
on a plus récemment
une vision
plus popularisée
du courant baptiste
réformé
qui n'était pas
présente
dans la confession
donc c'est une anachronie
de chercher
à
comment dire
à conformer
la position
plus courante
aujourd'hui
à la position
que nous sommes
en train d'étudier
dans les confessions
et c'est ce qu'on appelle
les dispensationalistes
alliancistes
dans quel sens ?
c'est pas l'essence
de l'eschatologie
par rapport
au dispensationalisme
mais c'est par rapport
à ces deux grandes administrations
de l'alliance des grâces
et donc pour
cette courante
plus populaire
dans nos jours
baptistes
ils vont considérer
par exemple
que la loi Mosaïque
est une nouvelle publication
quelque part
de l'alliance des œuvres
avec Moïse
et donc pour eux
il y a un changement
des substances
dans l'alliance
et ils auront
une tendance
à traiter
l'ancienne alliance
plutôt comme
l'alliance établie
avec Moïse
ok
et ça c'est pas
la position confessionnelle
c'est pas ma position personnelle
et donc c'est pas
la position
des premiers baptistes
des baptistes réformés
puritains
originaires
d'accord
et donc ça
on peut identifier
par cette piste
très claire
car ils ne veulent
même pas utiliser
l'expression
alliance des œuvres
dans la confession
des fois
et ils sont très clairs
pour insister
qu'il y a
une seule alliance
des grâces
sous deux administrations
et donc si nous voulons
être orthodoxes
et confessionnels
par rapport
aux réformés baptistes
c'est plutôt dans cette direction
que nous allons ensemble
pour ceux qui ne sont pas encore
en train de comprendre
les nuances
de ce que je suis en train de dire
ça sera plus clair
à partir des prochaines réunions
mais pour l'instant
c'est important
de remarquer
quelle était l'intention
des rédacteurs
de la confession baptiste
de ne pas utiliser
l'expression
alliance des œuvres
donc il y a
au moins
trois décisions intentionnelles
la première
c'était vraiment
de faire des efforts
pour nous rappeler
que même dans l'alliance
des vies
ou l'alliance des œuvres
comme vous voulez
il y avait
toujours
l'élément des grâces
et c'était
pour ne pas utiliser
un titre formel
une classification formelle
à aucune idée
méritoire
d'approche
ou d'abordage
envers Dieu
et donc là
ils ont préféré
de supprimer complètement
cette notion
d'alliance
des œuvres
donc dans leur conception
ils comprenaient
ils partageaient même
la position
de la confession
des fois de Westminster
donc ils n'étaient pas
contre le fédéralisme
ils étaient contre
cette possibilité
de supprimer
l'idée des grâces
même dans
les premiers pactes
les pactes
des vies
une autre raison
c'est que cet élément
des grâces
est toujours présent
même si
conditionné
par obéissance
donc qu'Adam
puisse
gagner la vie
ils partiraient
dans la direction
d'une grâce
accordée par Dieu
même si par alliance
conditionnée
par l'obéissance
et le troisième
c'est lui qui est peut-être
le plus intéressant
pour nous
pour la discussion
polémique
c'est la présence
de la polémique
antinomienne
dans cette génération
puritaine
donc plusieurs
étaient tellement
en train de mettre
l'emphase
sur la plénitude
de la nouvelle alliance
à point de suggérer
qu'il n'y aurait
plus
aucune
utilité
pour la loi
et donc
quel est
l'élément
qui doit être présent
même si
même dans une alliance
conditionnée par obéissance
il y a la grâce
ok
mais de l'autre côté
même dans une alliance
des grâces
l'obéissance
n'est jamais supprimée
il y aura toujours
cet élément
d'obéissance
car c'est une question
créationnelle
nous sommes créatures
de Dieu
nous sommes toujours
et serons à toujours
indépendamment
de notre capacité
ou non d'obéir
nous sommes toujours
obligés
à obéir Dieu
et ça fait partie
de l'alliance
des grâces
nous rendre capables
et nous pousser
envers l'obéissance
ok
et donc voilà pourquoi
ils ont voulu
éviter
utiliser
ces langages
afin de se protéger
de ces choses là
et donc
ensuite on est parti
pour faire un survol
sur les alliances
dans la Bible
si on peut passer
on va partir
un peu plus vite
je ne vais pas revenir
à tous ces points
mais on a vu
que toutes ces alliances
sur lesquelles
nous nous sommes médités
on est en train
d'identifier
qu'il s'agissait
des alliances
des grâces
donc avec Adam
c'était implicite
mais c'était suffisamment
clair
les éléments
d'une alliance
et on voit
par la suite
qu'à chaque fois
malgré la corruption
humaine
c'est Dieu
qui vient
avec une promesse
et chacune
de ces alliances
vont progresser
dans la communication
de quelque chose
qui va enrichir
notre compréhension
de manière préparatoire
de notre vrai besoin
d'un rédempteur
donc chacune de ces choses
était en train
de contribuer
à la compréhension
du besoin exact
qui nous avons
en tant
qui est nouveau représentant
nouvel Adam
quel type de sacrifice
quel type des ombres
etc.
tout était en train
de pointer
envers
les seigneurs Jésus Christ
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
ces deux extraits
de la confession
au paragraphe 2
bien plus
puisque l'homme
s'est placé
sous la malédiction
de la loi
par la chute
il n'a plus
au seigneur
de faire
une alliance
des grâces
ok
et ensuite
les paragraphes 3
cette alliance
est révélée
dans l'évangile
tout d'abord Adam
dans la promesse
du salut
par la postérité
de la femme
et par la suite
progressivement
jusqu'à la révélation
complète
dans le nouveau testament
donc là
on a vu
ces alliances
par un survol
mais nous avons
fait des remarques
importantes
surtout
sur trois alliances
et donc
les trois alliances
sont notamment
celles d'Adam
qui était la première
alliance des grâces
juste après la chute
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui vient
qui pourvoit
quelque part
la satisfaction
des conditions
donc c'est Dieu
qui va tuer les animaux
les couvrir avec les peaux
etc
donc il y a du sang versé
même des choses
qui plus tard
seraient communiquées
de manière plus claire
et formelle
comme exigence
c'était déjà présent
car Dieu était en train
d'anticiper déjà
dans la pratique
mais clairement
il y avait la promesse
de la réconciliation
avec Dieu
donc l'inimitié
entre les serpents
car c'était l'amitié
avec les serpents
qui nous a conduits
à la chute
et donc là
il y avait la promesse
de réconciliation
avec Dieu
cet espoir
de retour au paradis
mais donc
c'était implicite
mais clair
car ça exigeait
de la part d'Adam
la foi
donc il a fait la promesse
Adam a cru
nous le savons
car il a changé
le nom des femmes
à Ève
et par là
il a été d'accord
pour la promesse
de Dieu
et dans l'espoir
que c'est lui
qui a été promis
ou celui
à qui la promesse
était faite
c'est intéressant
car quelque part
la promesse
est faite
dans la présence d'Adam
mais la promesse
elle est plutôt
communiquée
par rapport à
et envers
un descendant
qui viendrait
de la femme
donc ça c'est très intéressant
à remarquer
c'est vraiment
la mention
du Christ
qui viendrait
qui est déjà là
la sémence
de la femme
qui viendra
régler
toute cette problématique
et donc là
il y a la base
de cette alliance
qui va encadrer
par la grâce
des dieux
les développements
de ces plans
de la rédemption
qui a été promis
déjà
à Adam et Ève
donc ensuite
avec Abraham
la Bible
elle est explicite
et très récurrente
pour fonder
sur cette alliance
avec Abraham
ou reconnaître
dans cette alliance
avec Abraham
sa manifestation
la plus formelle
et primaire
c'est-à-dire
c'est la première
alliance établie
par Dieu
de manière formelle
où Dieu
donc l'expression
pour dire
établir une alliance
dans les contextes
historiques
et dans les termes
originaux
ça veut dire
couper une alliance
donc Dieu
il a coupé
une alliance
avec Abraham
avant la circoncision
avant
430 ans
avant la loi
et donc
l'argument
d'Epaules
en Gala 3
c'est l'un des passages
les plus importants
qui aura aussi
beaucoup d'implications
quand on verra
la manière d'interpréter
qu'est-ce qui continue
qu'est-ce qui ne continue pas
à qui appliquer
les signes de l'alliance
donc pour nous
qui sommes
credo-baptistes
c'est un texte
capital
à maîtriser
car là
l'alliance
mosaïque
ne peut jamais
être considérée
comme quelque chose
contraire à l'alliance
des grâces
elle est subsidiaire
elle est en train
d'enrichir
la compréhension
par exemple
du sacrifice parfait
qui Christ doit être
les exigences
de pureté
la notion
du fait
qui Christ doit être
comme les suprêmes
sacrificateurs
et tout cela
sera repris par Hebreu
pour démontrer
mais pour l'implication
contre la position
baptiste plus populaire
aujourd'hui
c'est ça
mais aussi
contre la position
pédobaptiste
c'est cette notion
que ce n'est pas
l'alliance
la plus chargée
comme celle
des Moïse
qui sera
les paramètres
pour comprendre
l'alliance
du Nouveau Testament
au contraire
toute l'emphase
du Nouveau Testament
par rapport
à la loi
mosaïque
était vraiment
de nous décrocher
de nous détacher
de tout l'échafaudage
qui a été rajouté
car c'était
pour rajouter
par grâce
surtout
la notion
du besoin
de purification
de péché
d'expiation
qui était totalement
nécessaire
comme dernière étape
d'emphase
pour la venue
du Christ
et donc
la loi mosaïque
elle est
quelque part
la plus chargée
en termes
d'éléments
et de formalités
l'alliance
mosaïque
ok
par contre
l'argumentation
de Paul
c'est que
l'alliance
essentielle
qui doit servir
plutôt des paramètres
pour nous
c'est cette promesse
que Dieu a fait
à Christ
à travers Abraham
de bénir
toutes les nations
en Abraham
et la nature
du peuple de la foi
c'est la foi
c'est les vrais Israels
c'est le peuple
de la foi
donc on reviendra
sur ces emphases
mais c'est très important
pour nous
pour l'instant
de faire ces deux remarques
qui seront
très utiles pour nous
quand on sera dans les débats
ou dans les discussions
par rapport aux positions
d'alliance
et donc
Moïse
c'est intéressant
car c'était une alliance
subsidiaire
et quelque part
inférieure
dans un certain sens
car
Dieu a traité
directement
avec Abraham
il a fait Abraham
endormi
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui passe par les couloirs
des animaux
en disant
ça va retomber sur moi
mais c'est intéressant
c'est Dieu lui-même
qui coupe cette alliance
avec Abraham
ok
par contre
avec Moïse
dans l'argumentation
de l'apôtre
dans ses passages
c'est-à-dire
il y avait encore
d'autres médiateurs
donc c'était Dieu
à travers les anges
envers Moïse
et Moïse
en tant que représentant
du peuple
au lieu
directement
et donc c'est important
Paul l'apôtre
il est en train
de donner
toutes ses argumentations
pour dire
c'est impossible
que l'alliance
mosaïque
soit comprise
comme quelque chose
qui s'oppose
à la grâce
qu'elle est en train
de contribuer
avec laquelle
elle est en train
de servir
pour la compréhension
c'est pour enrichir
la compréhension
du Christ
même si l'emphase
particulière
de la loi
mosaïque
ou de l'alliance
c'est notamment
toutes ses exigences
donc là
au verset 12
depuis le verset 12
c'est très clair
et c'est important
or la loi
n'est pas fondée
sur la foi
mais elle dit
celui qui mettra
ces choses en pratique
vivra par elle
et donc
qu'est-ce qu'il veut dire
par là
il est en train de dire
que si nous voulons
prendre la loi
à la lettre
c'est comme si
on croyait
qu'il y aurait
être possible
pour nous
de l'accomplir
par contre
Christ nous a racheté
de la malédiction
de la loi
étant devenu
malédiction pour nous
c'est à dire
si Christ
a dû devenir
malédiction pour nous
c'est car l'objectif
de la loi
c'était pour montrer
que c'était impossible
dès le départ
qu'aucune personne
n'accomplisse la loi
donc l'objectif
de la loi
c'est pour montrer
l'abondance
de péché
de la corruption
l'impossibilité
de l'accomplir
notamment pour qu'on
dépende complètement
que Christ soit maudit
à notre place
vous comprenez
et ça c'est grâce
mais donc là
je ne peux pas rentrer
dans tous les détails
de passage
les principales
ont été dits
et on avance
pour la transition
avec
donc là
c'est juste
pour que ça soit clair
pour nous
les éléments
essentiels
d'une alliance
ceux qu'on va les trouver
par exemple
dans l'alliance
avec Adam
des grâces
ou l'alliance
avec Abraham
ce sont les deux parties
les promesses
les conditions
les sanctions
d'accord
et quand on pense
à tous les éléments
qui ont fait partie
de cette alliance
qui sont vraiment
très beau
et très gracieux
aussi
déjà une alliance
qui a été faite
après
la délivrance
donc ce n'était pas
une condition
pour les saluts
car les saluts
avaient déjà eu lieu
Israël était déjà
libéré de l'Egypte
donc c'était pour
sanctifier
les peuples
plutôt
que pour sauver
les peuples
si vous voulez
et donc à partir de là
nous voyons
que cet accord
entre Dieu
et les peuples
il est basé
sur les pactes
des
hittites
des païens
des peuples
païens
anciens
et donc c'est intéressant
il y avait
un préambule
on voit de manière
très claire là
tous les préambules
que Dieu fait
en montrant
qu'il était
le responsable
pour la délivrance
d'Israël
en ayant démontré
toute sa puissance
sur la montagne
quand Dieu va maîtriser
par exemple
la nouée
qui descend
avec tous les tonnerres
les tremblements
des terres
les feux
etc
c'était pour vous montrer
en rappel
en contraste avec l'Egypte
qu'ils avaient
plusieurs dieux
chacun prenant soin
d'un élément
et Dieu est en train
de montrer
moi je suis le seul vrai dieu
les dieux au-dessus
de tout autre dieu
je peux maîtriser
toutes ces choses
en même temps
c'était un préambule
c'était la gloire
des dieux
en s'avançant
et quand il parle
tout le monde tremble
etc
je vous rappelle
c'était très intéressant
de remarquer
ces préambules divins
en disant
moi je vous ai libérés
pour être
une nation royale
une nation sainte
pardon
un royaume
des prêtres
et pour être
mon trésor personnel
et donc
ensuite
il y a les deux parties
donc cette représentation
médiée par Moïse
d'un côté
Dieu de l'autre côté
et qui donne
la loi
ou les tables
qui sont
comme les contrats signés
car dans la pratique
de ces nations
ce qu'ils faisaient
à l'époque
c'est que chacun
ou chaque nation
gardait
la copie
qu'ils ont signée
ok
et les deux copies
étaient mises
dans un lieu public
pour consultation
comme on peut aller
dans certaines bibliothèques
nationales
pour aller regarder
par exemple
la constitution
d'un pays
ou des choses comme ça
et donc ça
c'était plutôt
la constitution
les dix commandements
qui scellaient
ces pactes
et donc
les sceaux
de cette alliance
formelle
elle était gardée
ou les symboles
pour l'accès
donc quand on pense
aux deux tables
de la loi
parfois on pense
que c'était
quatre commandements
six commandements
mais les plus
probable
ce sont
deux copies
des mêmes dix commandements
qui étaient présents
et donc on voit
vraiment la manière
très généreuse
dont Dieu a fait tout ça
et même si
Israël
ne serait pas capable
d'accomplir
toutes ces conditions
dans la loi
des dieux
il avait aussi
pourvu
à l'expiation
pour apaiser
et donc même
la provision
du casser
les conditions
nous montre
que c'était
plutôt une déviation
de ces conditions
qui devraient tomber
sur les peuples
mais qui en fait
va retomber
sur Dieu lui-même
Christ
car les feux
qui a traversé
les couloirs d'Abraham
c'est les mêmes
qui sont en train
de supporter
cette même alliance
des grâces
et donc c'est
une théophonie
une manifestation
du Christ préincarné
en forme de feu
qui est en train
de passer ses cris
sur lui-même
et donc
voilà
les éléments
d'une alliance
et nous sommes arrivés
à la définition
biblique
d'une alliance
une alliance
c'est un pacte
solennel
par lesquels
Dieu
par initiative
souveraine
et condescendance
divine
s'élit à l'homme
pour son salut
et sa bénédiction
contrairement aux alliances
humaines
entre parties égales
Dieu prend la priorité
initiative
s'engagant
à tenir ses promesses
indépendamment
de la capacité
humaine
et là c'est déjà
une transition plus
pour l'alliance
des grâces
cette alliance
peut comporter
des conditions
pour l'homme
des signes
de cérémonie
mais elle
reflète toujours
la grâce
et la miséricorde
des dieux
et trouve son
accomplissement
ultime
dans l'oeuvre
rédemptrice
de Christ
ok
donc
la conclusion
pour nous
en ayant considéré
tous ces éléments
d'alliance
des grâces
dans l'Ancien Testament
c'est qu'il y a
une seule alliance
des grâces
révélée progressivement
!
administrée par deux
dispensations
l'alliance des grâces
dans l'athée
est appelée
l'ancienne alliance
pleinement révélée
dans le Nouveau Testament
et l'alliance
des grâces
pleinement révélée
dans le Nouveau Testament
est appelée
la nouvelle alliance
on peut passer là
et là c'est un schéma
qui nous montre
plus ou moins
il y a
cette alliance
éternelle
que Dieu a établie
au-dedans
de soi-même
entre trinitaires
avant la fondation
du monde
et donc
Dieu va conduire
par la manière
dont il va gouverner
l'histoire
ces alliances
qui vont révéler
progressivement
les pactes
de la rédemption
jusqu'à ce qu'il
Christ arrive
et donc
l'Ancien Testament
avec toutes ces alliances
progressives
qui pointent
envers Christ
elles sont appelées
l'ancienne alliance
ou l'ancienne dispensation
de l'alliance des grâces
et là
nous
on est privilégié
de réjouir
de la nouvelle alliance
en Jésus-Christ
donc il y a
une seule alliance
des grâces
révélées progressivement
administrées par deux
dispensations
anciennes dans l'Ancien Testament
nouvelles dans les Nouveaux Testaments
!
donc pour avancer un peu
aujourd'hui
la première question
qu'on va se poser
aujourd'hui
c'est
pourquoi
nouvelle alliance
ça c'est une question
très importante
car
l'une des raisons
pour laquelle
on va rater
la compréhension
de ces deux
dispensations
ou de la
distinction
entre ces deux
dispensations
c'est car
parfois
le fait
que les titres
nouvelle alliance
soient utilisés
dans la Bible
est pris
de manière
plus littérale
que didatique
ou expérimentale
car si nous voulons
penser en termes
de nouvelle alliance
et si on est
très littéral
par rapport à ça
là
on est en train
de considérer
qu'elle est peut-être
substantiellement
ou essentiellement
déconnectée
de l'ancienne alliance
sauf que la Bible
elle est claire
pour démontrer
qu'il y a
un seul
ou une seule
alliance
des grâces
donc c'est la même
alliance
et comment devons-nous
comprendre
nouvelle
ou la nouvelle alliance
comme nouvelle
ces nouvelles
ne se dirigent pas
pardon
donc
ces nouvelles
ne se dirigent pas
à l'essence
ou la substance
de l'alliance
ça reste
l'alliance des grâces
la même alliance
mais
c'est clair
qu'à chaque fois
surtout
que l'alliance
des grâces
apparaît
ou la nouvelle alliance
les termes
nouvelle alliance
apparaît dans la Bible
il va mettre
toute son emphase
non forcément
dans quelque chose
qui fait une séparation
entre grâce
et mérite
ou non grâce
mais
c'est un niveau
d'intensité
c'est plutôt
au niveau
d'expérience
et donc
l'expérience
elle est
tellement
différente
en termes
d'intensité
elle est
tellement
plus élevée
plus puissante
plus glorieuse
plus claire
plus limpide
plus légère
c'est quelque chose
qui est tellement
différent
de cette expérience
religieuse
des vies
et des pratiques
que nous ne pouvons pas
appeler autre chose
que nouvelle
c'est à dire
la Bible
elle est très intéressée
pour que l'expérience
avec la nouvelle alliance
soit une expérience
légère
nouvelle
glorieuse
des célébrations
donc si vous imaginez
à nouveau
tout l'échafaudage
pour l'Ancien Testament
notamment à partir
de toutes les lois
mosaïques
l'expérience
religieuse
même
des saints
légitimes
car la majorité
n'était même pas
des saints légitimes
la réalité
c'est que
dans leur expérience
des fois
tout était
lourd
obscur
tout était
par des ombres
même si
toutes ces choses
étaient fondées
sur une alliance
des grâces
c'est la grâce
des dieux
qui fait
qu'on transpire
pour
prendre un agneau
prier sur lui
sacrifier
et confesser
aux sacrificateurs
et qu'une fois par année
on a eu
tous ces systèmes
d'expiation
de toute la nation
et donc
toute cette difficulté
d'accéder au trône des grâces
à la présence
des dieux
etc
toute cette lourdeur
était grâce
déjà
c'était quand même
la possibilité
de s'approcher
des dieux
c'était quand même
la possibilité
de comprendre
que moi je suis un pécheur
et je peux
par la grâce de Dieu
transférer mon péché
à un autre
même qui est représenté
par cet animal
mais c'était pas clair
en fait
de quelle manière
Dieu ne serait pas
qu'apaisé
par ces choses
mais Dieu
il serait véritablement
satisfait
dans sa demande
des justes colères
et donc
c'était la grâce
oui
mais c'était une grâce
qui
quand on arrive
à la nouvelle alliance
l'expérience
elle est tellement différente
qu'on se porte
beaucoup plus
sur ce qui est nouveau
qu'on se porte
beaucoup plus
sur l'aspect
concrétisé
réalisé
l'aspect élevé
et glorieux
qu'est
les rudiments
anciens
donc tout cela
apportera
plein d'implications
à plusieurs égards
mais pour l'instant
c'est très important
de remarquer aussi
cette piste
à nouveau
pour nous préparer
pour les questions
des discussions
des positions théologiques
car
la comparaison
est les moyens
les plus efficaces
les seuls moyens
quelque part
de faire la distinction
entre l'ancienne
et la nouvelle alliance
et par la comparaison
nous allons voir
qu'il y a beaucoup
de similarités
mais il y a aussi
encore plus
de différences
vous êtes avec moi
et la grande question
qu'on doit se poser
c'est ok
nous allons comparer
l'ancienne alliance
avec la nouvelle
qui devrait avoir
la priorité
pour déterminer
notre compréhension
de l'alliance
car par exemple
dans certains débats
nous
on va
on va plutôt
s'accrocher
à la notion
de sola scriptura
et les autres
vont essayer
de nous rappeler
non sola scriptura
oui mais aussi
tota scriptura
c'est à dire
toute l'écriture
et bien sûr
par contre
nous sommes tous
d'accord
dans tous les autres
domaines théologiques
que les nouveaux
testaments
à la prééminence
d'interprétation
sur l'ancien testament
par contre
quand on arrive
aux discussions
de la théologie
de l'alliance
parfois on a l'impression
qu'on veut donner
plus d'importance
à ce qui était
plus obscur
dans l'ancien testament
voilà pourquoi
galate
il est capitale
pour corriger
quelques précipitations
qu'on puisse avoir
mais
la comparaison
elle est moyen
pour comprendre
ce qui est nouveau
ce qui n'est pas nouveau
donc c'est à dire
je dois comparer
l'expérience
de l'alliance
des grâces
dans l'ancien testament
avec l'expérience
de l'alliance
des grâces
dans le nouveau testament
sauf que
la priorité
majeure
c'est
de comprendre
la nouvelle alliance
dans les cadres
de la nouvelle alliance
et permettre
que la nouvelle alliance
m'aide à comprendre
l'ancienne alliance
et les distinctions
vous êtes avec moi
donc c'est pas
pour donner un exemple
l'alliance mosaïque
la plus formalisée
qui va avoir
un poids
pour que je reproduise
la notion d'alliance
dans le nouveau testament
donc je dois
contempler surtout
les langages directs
la description biblique
directe
sur cette nouvelle alliance
et quand j'arrive
au nouveau testament
c'est
les peuples de la foi
c'est l'alliance
des grâces
de la réalisation
de la circoncision
du coeur
et quand je vois
toutes ces choses là
je n'ai pas besoin
de traiter
l'alliance mosaïque
comme une alliance
d'oeuvres
pour arriver
à la conclusion
que c'est clair
et évident
dans le nouveau testament
que les peuples
de la nouvelle alliance
par des sens divins
c'est les peuples
de la réalité
de la foi
on n'a plus l'intérêt
d'anticiper
ou d'attendre
quelque chose
même car
quand on est
avec Israël
on n'avait pas forcément
besoin
d'attendre
aucune chose
en termes
des participations
légitimes
dans les peuples
si on traverse
la circoncision
une fois
appliquée
je suis considéré
comme membre
d'Israël
vous êtes avec moi
et la réalité
c'est que
les doubles rôles
d'Israël
c'était faire partie
d'un peuple
qui avait un rôle
didatique
de la part des dieux
un rôle pédagogique
provisoire
temporel
et ça
ce n'est pas la réalité
dans les nouveaux testaments
car dans les nouveaux testaments
on n'a plus rien à attendre
l'anticipation
de la circoncision
était dans son rôle double
l'attente du Messie
qui viendrait
par ces peuples ethniques
c'est nécessaire
pour la bénédiction
de toutes les nations
par contre
une fois Christ arrivé
il n'y a plus d'attente
dans les nouveaux testaments
la marque
qui ne laisse même pas
des marques
les baptêmes
il est réservé
selon nos convictions
clairement
sur cette base là
car
c'est évident
que les symboles
et la nature
de l'alliance
du Nouveau Testament
ne laissent
aucune chose
à attendre
en termes
d'accomplissement
pour l'alliance
bien sûr
que les résultats
final
on est encore
en train d'attendre
c'est à dire
la gloire
les retours du Christ
mais tout ce qui concerne
la réjouissance
de la promesse
tout ce qui concerne
l'accomplissement
de ce qui était nécessaire
même car
quand Jésus est venu
les juifs
n'ont pas été
automatiquement
sauvés
ce sont ceux
qui sont ceux
de la foi
d'Abraham
qui ont pu participer
qui ont été exhortés
à croire
et donc nous
on ne peut pas
communiquer
par les symboles
qui visent à représenter
l'alliance
que nous sommes
en train d'attendre
quelque chose
s'accomplir
les sceaux
il doit être
efficace
pour sceller
et représenter
ce que l'alliance
représente
dans sa nature
c'est clair
et donc
la comparaison
est nécessaire
et la comparaison
est hiérarchique
on doit chercher
à trouver
dans les passages
bibliques
explicites
sur l'alliance
voilà
les répères
et la définition
plus claire
de ce qui est
la nouvelle alliance
et à partir de là
faire les distinctions
avec l'ancienne
donc
la première chose
que nous allons faire
aujourd'hui
et je pense qu'on va
s'arrêter là
c'est juste la lecture
de plusieurs textes
bibliques
qui nous parlent
de la nouvelle alliance
et donc
on peut prendre
Jérémie 31
verset 31
donc elle est
la didatique ici
j'ai déjà cité
quelques passages
du Nouveau Testament
on a commencé
par la lecture
des premières pierres
Matthieu 13
Jean 8
les textes
classiques
pour l'étude
de la nouvelle alliance
définie
dans les Nouveaux Testamentes
se trouvent
en hébreu
notamment
hébreu
10 à 12
mais il y a
un exercice
important
car on a
très peu
des textes
dans l'Ancien Testament
qui utilisent
l'expression
explicite
nouvelle alliance
et c'est surtout
là où on devrait
aussi
chercher
à définir
Jérémie 31
voici les jours
viennent
dit l'éternel
où je ferai
avec la maison
d'Israël
et la maison
de Jouda
une alliance
nouvelle
non comme
l'alliance
que j'ai traitée
avec leur père
les jours
où je les ai saisis
par l'amant
pour les faire sortir
du pays
d'Égypte
alliance
qu'ils ont
violée
quoique
je fusse leur maître
dit l'éternel
mais voici
l'alliance
que je ferai
avec la maison
d'Israël
après ce jour-là
dit l'éternel
je mettrai
ma loi
au-dedans
d'eux
j'écrirai
dans leur cœur
et j'essayerai
leur Dieu
et ils seront
mon peuple
celui-ci
n'enseignera plus
son prochain
ni celui-là
son frère
en disant
connaissez
l'éternel
car tous
me connaîtront
depuis les plus petits
jusqu'au plus grand
dit l'éternel
car je pardonnerai
leur iniquité
et je me souviendrai
ne me souviendrai plus
de leur péché
donc la question ici
l'emphase ici
c'est clairement
une question
de décrire
les peuples
de la nouvelle alliance
et les peuples exclusifs
comme ceux
qui connaissent Dieu
dans quel sens
tous les peuples
de la nouvelle alliance
connaissent Dieu
dans le nouveau testament
dans la manière
donc les saints esprits
ont été répandus
et tous ceux
qui ont connu
Christ
véritablement
par les saints esprits
ont reçu
une mesure
des connaissances
de l'évangile
infiniment supérieure
même aux prophètes
de l'ancien testament
mais les contrastes
il n'est pas forcément
tout simplement
entre les vrais chrétiens
de l'ancien testament
et les vrais chrétiens
du nouveau testament
il est en train
de faire les contrastes
entre
ces peuples
ethniques
Israël national
dont la majorité
n'était pas
véritablement
convertie
il y avait
ces pactes
cet encadrement
physique
externe
formel
qui cherchait
à communiquer
des principes
sur le rituel
mais la Bible
est claire
pour dire
qu'à chaque fois
à chaque génération
on a qui en reste
qui est
les vrais
Israels
et Paul
il met
tout cet emphase
là
quand il écrit
un roman
aux Galates
aux Hébreux
et il met
tout cet emphase
pour dire
que les vrais
peuples
de Dieu
et les peuples
de la foi
c'était toujours
comme ça
par contre
c'était légitime
et réel
dans ces cadres
d'alliances
de l'ancien testament
qu'un peuple
des majorités
non régénérées
soit là
pour servir
des écoles
élémentaires
pour toutes les nations
car les saluts
viendraient
de là
et donc ici
quand il dit
depuis les petits
jusqu'aux plus grands
dans l'original
c'est clair
on est en train
de parler
des positions sociales
on n'est pas en train
de parler
d'âge
et dans ces passages
nous sommes devant
la réalité
que la nouvelle alliance
est marquée
par
la connaissance
des dieux
on n'exhorte
plus
ceux qui sont
dans cette alliance
à connaître Dieu
à se convertir
car tous ceux
qui sont
dans cette alliance
connaissent Dieu
et connaissent Dieu
avec cette intimité
de la présence
du Saint-Esprit
Ézéchiel 36
je répandrai
sur vous
une eau pure
et vous serez purifiés
je vous purifierai
de toutes vos soleillures
et de toutes vos idoles
je vous donnerai
un cœur nouveau
et je mettrai en vous
un esprit nouveau
je taillerai
de votre corps
le cœur des pierres
et je vous donnerai
un cœur des chairs
je mettrai mon esprit
en vous
et je ferai
en sorte
que vous suivez
mes ordonnances
et que vous observez
et pratiquiez
mes lois
donc ici à nouveau
c'est l'un des textes
les plus importants
dans les contextes
plus larges
de la considération
de cette alliance
éternelle
car
quand on saute
au chapitre 37
verset 26
je ferai avec eux
une alliance
de paix
c'est une alliance
éternelle
avec eux
je les affermirai
et je les mettrai
en sécurité
et je susciterai
des blés
et je multiplierai
les fruits
je mettrai ma demeure
au milieu d'eux
et je serai leur dieu
ils seront mon peuple
et les nations
connaîtront
qu'est-moi l'éternel
j'ai senti Fils-Réë
lorsqu'en leur milieu
ma demeure sera
pour toujours
donc on sait
que l'habitation
des dieux
pour toujours
n'est pas
les temples
car ça serait
complètement anti-climax
car Christ lui-même
dit détruisez ces temples
en trois jours
j'essaierai la ressuscité
il parlait de lui-même
le Nouveau Testament
Pierre il nous dit
que nous sommes
les temples vivants
des dieux
la demeure des dieux
sommes-nous
et donc notamment
la description
du peuple des dieux
ce sont ceux
qui auront
le cœur régénéré
c'est plus
une communauté mixte
ça ne nous protège pas
absolument
d'arriver un jour
dans une église
où on soit sûr
qu'il y ait un quai
des chrétiens là-dedans
l'ivraie peut pousser
avec les blés
mais la réalité
c'est que l'église
est chargée
de maintenir la communion
et reconnaître
publiquement comme chrétien
seulement ceux
qui donnent
des évidences suffisantes
des conversions
donc ici c'est clair
aussi dans ces passages
ce qui concerne
la Nouvelle Alliance
Luc 22
vend
il prit
dès même la coupe
après avoir soupé
et leur donna
et disait
en disant
cette coupe
est la Nouvelle Alliance
en mon sang
qui est répandue
pour vous
acte 2
et là c'est clairement
la prédication
des pierres
mais c'est ici
ce qui a été dit
par les prophètes
Jérôles
dans les derniers jours
dit Dieu
!
c'est en acte 2
donc la descente
du Saint-Esprit
vos fils
et vos filles
prophétiseront
vos jeunes
gens
auront des visions
et vos veillards
auront des songes
donc c'est pas là
où on doit s'accrocher
même si ce sont
des privilèges
qui doivent être
plus attendus
dans la dispensation
du Saint-Esprit
mais la bénédiction
principale
c'est Dieu
qui par l'Esprit
vient faire habitation
dans son peuple
donc verset 18
oui
sur mes serviteurs
et sur mes servantes
dans ces jours-là
je répandrai
de mon esprit
en ces alliances
le Saint-Esprit
bien sûr
travaillait
pour la régénération
et la conversion
des vrais sang
et il opérait
de manière
plus ponctuelle
sur certaines personnes
avec cette onction
particulière
par contre
venir habiter
et demeurer
chez tous les chrétiens
c'est quelque chose
de nouveau
c'est le Saint-Esprit
qui n'est pas en train
d'opérer
de manière timide
ou de manière ponctuelle
mais c'est un esprit
qui est en train
d'opérer
de manière
à être répandu
sur tous les vrais chrétiens
et ils prophétiseront
et Pierre leur dit
répandez-vous
et remarquez bien
c'est une déclaration
qui n'est pas en train
comment vous dites
pour les catholiques
là
emprêtée
qui n'est pas en train
de communiquer
le Saint-Esprit
par imposition
c'est pas automatique
c'est pas la nouvelle alliance
là
donc tous les juifs
et ses descendants
tenez le Saint-Esprit
pour vous
c'est la promesse
non
il y a même
pour les juifs
clairement dans ces passages
cette condition
quelle condition
répandez-vous
et croyez
à la promesse
donc remarquez bien
verset 17
dans les derniers jours
pardon
verset
répandez-vous
et que chacun de vous
soit baptisé
en nom de Jésus-Christ
!
pour les pardons
de vos péchés
et vous recevrez
les dons du Saint-Esprit
donc
comme
cette
récompense
cette promesse
accomplie
l'habitation des dieux
la circoncision du cœur
etc
l'enseignement
il viendra habiter
chez ceux
qui démontrent
cette répentance
et cette foi
car la promesse
est pour vous
donc dans quel sens
pas d'automatique
mais
conditionnée par la foi
donc la nouvelle alliance
les peuples de la foi
toutes les chers appelés
car la promesse
est pour vous
pour vos enfants
c'est-à-dire
votre descendance
ok
elle reste la promesse
pour vous
pour vos enfants
sous condition
que vous ayez compris
bien l'évangile
qui a été prêché
dans l'ancienne alliance
la foi
dans la provision divine
la foi d'Abraham
et pas cette mauvaise
compréhension légaliste
hypocrite
pharisaïque
nationaliste
ethnique
qui était là
corrompu
c'est la foi
qui caractérise
les vrais
Israël de Dieu
car la promesse
est pour vous
vos enfants
là il n'est pas
en train de dire
il est juste en train
de répéter
cette réalité
la promesse
est pour toutes
les régénérations
sous quelles conditions
sous les mêmes conditions
qui étaient au départ
répandez-vous
et soyez baptisés
et la même condition
qui est en train
de qualifier
les versets 39
et pour tous ceux
qui sont au loin
un aussi grand nombre
que les seigneurs
notre Dieu
l'appellera
donc qu'est-ce qui détermine
ceux qui participeront
qu'est-ce qui détermine
les peuples
de l'alliance
ceux qui sont
scellés par l'esprit
et donc
qui doivent être remarqués
tous ceux
qui Dieu
appellera
tous ceux
qui se montreront
répentis
tous ceux
qui vont
croire
à l'évangile
et donc
nous devons
nous arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
en ayant considéré
quelques textes
qui nous permettent
de nous habituer
un peu plus
mais on pourrait
citer
ces principes
du Nouveau Testament
de manière générale
par exemple
la pratique
de la discipline
des membriétés
responsables
qui présuppose
la protection
d'une membriété
qui soit
la membriété
de la foi
les peuples
donc on va
s'arrêter ici
et nous allons
la semaine prochaine
considérer
de manière plus objective
les distinctions
et les similarités
entre les deux alliances
et les deux
les deux